elle le verdict des jours le défenseur
international français kourouma a été
condamné en fin de matinée par la
justice britannique à 180 heures de
travaux d'intérêt général pour avoir
maltraité son chat le joueur de west ham
de 27 ans avait plaidé coupable
il s'est également vu interdire par le
tribunal de l'est de londres de détenir
un chat durant cinq ans tout est parti
de la vidéo qui avait été divisée par
son frère sur les réseaux sociaux où on
voyait de le joueur donné un coup de
pied nu claque à son animal alors pour
ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu les images
non on va les rendre ce qui est
important de les revoir tu devais ses
ailes sont horribles mais ça arrive très
souvent un regard des
deux celui qui filme et l'autre et de
soi-même ou d'aidé en plus il a été
condamné à 180 heures de travaux
filet ancien club oui ils ont vendu à
5000 euros de son club mais il aurait dû
payer une amende de la part de la
justice et ça méritait est plus je pense
à plat le signal qu'on envoie il est
terrible on allait dire qu'en fait
tabasser son animal c'est pas très grave
pour sentir en faisant du jardinage pour
sa commune je suis désolé c'est
extrêmement grave qu'il a fait il doit
être condamné plus lourdement que ça
bien sûr et surtout qu'on sait qu'il les
fera jamais et en plus ce que je trouve
terrible dans la décision de justice et
qu'on lui interdit pendant cinq ans
d'avoir un chat c'est à dire que dans
cinq ans il peut se faire mal et il peut
continuer de 2,2 le terroriser vol
traumatisés ah mais c'est hallucinant
sur il devrait être au moins viré du
club suspendu pendant chez paou droit sa
21e et franchement ça du tout cause
animale malsain pimentant dans la ja ça
va être testé en france en france les
lois sont plus plus quand même plus dur
très dur dur maigrir votre vélo à son
nom mais en attendant si elle est comme
il ya ya ya une reconnaissance quand
même du statut pour pour l'animal et
qu'on peut plus faire n'importe quoi
comme avant justement je trouve qu'il
faudrait que maintenant il y ait des
permis de détention pour un chien pour
un chat qu'on fasse au moins un stage de
trois jours savoir leurs besoins et tout
ça c'est hyper important mais
franchement on aurait pu mettre un
exemple ce monsieur gagne assez d'argent
donc en fait on aurait pu lui mettre une
petite amende comme ça et effectivement
j'ai bien peur qu'il ne fasse pas cessé
ses heures de même travaux
ça me désole qu'on puisse pas au moins
faire un exemple quoi c'est c'est triste
a été tellement médiatisé ça aurait pu
être le déclic au monde mais est ce
que vous allez me dire est-ce qu'on est
l'arrivée ce réseau leur en prison
sinon mais non à la question est ce que
la prison avec sursis moi j'aurais mis
prison avec sursis
oblitère diction d'abord rien n'est pas
rien mais non mais quand même oui mais
c'est déjà assez bien bien si tu grille
un feu masse et 50 kg
ils ont fermé fusent les mois une
semaine de prison ferme le m bordeaux
n'est qu'un problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui comme tu envoies un
violeur qui est un bracelet électronique
il vaut mieux mettre des normes et des
gens qui sont très dangereux pour lui
même en prison et parce qu'on dit kevin
est dangereux prévenu moment lieu
dangereux pour les animaux je suis
d'accord avec toi il faut il faut punir
formé par les prisons se trouvèrent des
privés ou massa n'a pas assez mal ou
alors est construit pour l'aspect enfin
déclaré le virer de son club parce qu'un
footballeur aujourd'hui la des
responsabilités d'image et de nom des
valeurs auxquelles auraient dû être viré
de son club parce qu'il peut pas
représenter ce genre d'image et ensuite
viré des réseaux sociaux parce que ces
images là elles sont sur les réseaux est
aujourd'hui sur les raisons
hésitation par accoucher à saha sont
truqués qui va se retrouver ben en fait
au point de départ là il va comprendre
la douleur et c'est là qu'il va être
puni c'est cool c'est vrai le problème
c'est le fruit de réseaux sociaux
d'affaires un peu les bisounours
j'aimerais que ce soit comme ça et que
tu es raison le problème c'est que il
n'y a quand même pas mal de voleurs qui
ont des histoires
voilà extra sportives on va dire est que
peu de clubs prennent des sanctions
alors qu'il devrait d'abord comme la
lame et francesca dedans dans l'image
serait que à la raison il fallait faire
un exemple on peut pas laisser
impunément quelqu'un sur ton ami sacha
il prend le chat pour un ballon et qu'il
ya un enfant sur les images donc
l'exemple bel exemple il a posté donc
c'est ça qui est fou c'est à dire qu il
n ya pas de regrets dans sa musique ne
s'en rend pas compte de la gravité voilà
c'est presque vente et en plus
c'est pas une bagarre d'accuser moi mais
j'aime vraiment vraiment qu'on se soucie
pas de la faute d'orthographe dans ces
moments là
pourquoi moi j'en fais énormément donc
alors il a quand même remercier la
reverse aussi un peu d'argent aux assos
n'ont pas d'égaux n'est rien du tout le
mec il est peinard
dans la chaise qu'ils auraient dû le
dire et du club suis complètement
d'accord ils passent une semaine de tall
sall aurait fait du bien et bah des dons
grâce aux réseaux sociaux se sont
exister et se sont super à tout le monde
eh ben c'est il faut il faut punir faut
pas ces gens-là il est une si grande
visibilité sont dangereux écoutez si le
g20 qui sifflent c'est le jeu mais
écoute monsieur zuma vous savez du souci
à vous faire mais c'est vrai que c'est
honnêtement blague à part c'est
absolument insupportable il est grand
temps que les lois soient faites pour
effectivement sur punir ceux qui font du
mal à nous parce que là bon il lui fait
mal mais il ya des choses bien pires en
est ce qu'il est mais on
voit la décision en france pour avoir
n'importe quel animal sa détention comme
comme une arme oui un permis par exemple
un stage de trois jours à prendre ce
qu'il faut pour un chien comme roland
jourdain
bien sûr compter sur la raison c'est
quand même ce qui va vraiment suer c'est
de vraiment l'animal s'était pas
vraiment vouloir faire ce cas là
faudrait que les gens qui vont être
parents aussi ça c'est well as koupèla
allez on va avancer le canada où vous
disent n'importe quoi là maintenant